when an event occurs in the HTML Dom
JavaScript code can be executed an
example of an event is when a user
clicks on an HTML element to execute
code when a user clicks on an element
just AB JavaScript code to the on click
HTML attribute if you look at the HTML
section we have the onclick attribute
and there's a JavaScript command right
in here this dot inner HTML equals
serial so I don't have anything in the
JavaScript section over here but still
when I click on what is my favorite food
it becomes serial you'll notice I also
have some CSS here this is kind of just
for fun I just thought it was kind of
cool that you can use the word papaya
whip and your browser knows that's a
color that's just a built in color
papaya whip now besides running a
command right here we can also call a
function from our other JavaScript code
so if we have the onclick event we can
call change color and then pass in this
that means we're passing in this h1 tag
we're passing in this whole thing here
to the change color function so over in
the JavaScript section we're gonna put
this change color function it's gonna
take a object-- and then we're gonna do
object dot style dot color equals Peru
because Peru is not just a country it's
a color also at least according to your
browser so I've reset this if I click
here it's now changed to the color Peru
now on these two we set the onclick
event right in the HTML however you can
also set the onclick event in the
JavaScript so here's a button here and
there's nothing in this button that
shows what happens when you click the
button but over in the JavaScript I'm
gonna put in some code here first we're
going to get that element document dot
get element by ID my button that's this
button over here and then we're going to
set an on click event right in the
JavaScript and the event is set to
change background color to medium orchid
now this is just a function call that we
now have to create okay here's the
function function change back and
florida medium orchid and we're gonna do
document
very selector body so that's gonna apply
to the whole body of the HTML and we're
gonna set the style dot background to me
orchid medium orchid is another color in
your browser if I click the button here
it's medium orchid for the background so
that's how you can change the background
of your whole page besides I'll click
you can also use on load or on unload so
that would be something like this you
would normally put it on your body tag
which would be at the beginning and cope
in you don't use a body tag but if you
put an onload event on your body and you
run a function here these events are
often triggered when the user enters or
leaves the page and they often are used
to deal with cookies
when you're just using the onload and on
unload but we're not going to use this
right now so another thing I wanted to
show you is on input let's bring this
down a little bit on input means
whenever you input any characters or
anything it's going to call a function
here so here we have the text box down
here and now every time I put in any
letter it's calling a function I've
created the function yes and now it's
not doing anything so let's create that
function so the function is remove
letter from h1 so we're gonna set h1
variable to document that query selector
h1 that's just gonna select the first h1
tag on the HTML page which is this one
up here now we're going to find the h1
text content that's the text inside the
h1 right here what is my favorite food
and we're gonna set that equal to h1
text content so we're saying that
setting equal to itself but then we're
slicing it passing in 0 negative 1 that
means we're just taking off the last
letter of that field now this whole
function is kind of just for fun just to
see what you can do so let's see how it
works as you can see every time I type a
letter another letter from that h1 tag
gets removed also interestingly anytime
I delete a letter something is removed
too because I'm putting an input of the
lead and it's still
removing letters oh the whole text is
gone and let me show you some other
events you can do so here I have a div
and there's an on mouse-over event that
calls this function here and it passes
in the div and we have an on Mouse out
event that calls the amount function and
passes in the div again and we have a
class of box so let me put some CSS in
here to make it look how we want it to
look so dot box just means we're setting
the class box to have these things for
background we're using the color Rebekah
purple for some reason Rebekah gets her
own purple and then the color of the
text is light goldenrod yellow one of
the longest text names and then we're
just gonna set the height and the width
the font size and some other things so
let's see what that looks like and
there's the box and right now if we
mouse over and Mouse out nothing happens
so let's create these JavaScript
functions to em over and out okay here's
mo ver and we're receiving this object
this gets passed into it and we're
setting that obscene or HTML to get off
me and then for an out
which means Mouse out or setting the
inner HTML - thank you smiley face
because you can put emoji in JavaScript
code so let's see what happens
I'm gonna bring my mouse over over Oh
get out me thank you
get off me thank you there are a lot of
other events that you can use to trigger
JavaScript code check the link in the
description to see a list of more events
also in the description is a link to the
code from this video on code pin thanks
for watching my name is beau Carnes
don't forget to subscribe and remember
use your code for good